black lives matter founder Patrice
cullers is furious with President Biden
and other top democrats for trying to
distance the party from the defund the
police movement she says quote there has
been deep cowardice from officials the
people who hold the power have chosen
not to wield it on behalf of black life
they've chosen to side with violent
police forces that comes as Congress
tries to give police reform another shot
Congressman Jim Clyburn is urging his
fellow Democrats to compromise this time
so that they can actually get something
done all right Jesse you know when
you've got Congressman Jim Clyburn okay
who's urging the Dems to give some
ground saying basically that you know if
you can't get a perfect piece of
legislation let's try for a good piece
yeah is that a starter
not for me I don't want police reform I
think the police are doing a great job I
see some of these things they're trying
to do Banning choke hold sometimes you
need to get the arm around the neck to
subdue the guy and now people are afraid
to even go near the neck and bad things
can happen the no knock warrants I don't
know enough about it but I do know what
it's going to do if they do it they're
just gonna instead of no knocking
they're gonna go knock boom and hit the
battering ram the immunity thing so then
you can get sued for millions of dollars
for something that happens on the job no
other Union has that that teachers
unions don't have that why do police
have that I don't like that they're
getting singled out and Joe Biden
probably likes the fact that some black
lives matter Thief
a lot of money is telling him you're a
bad guy for not defunting the police
that makes Joe Biden look good
okay you're nodding ahead Greg
absolutely right uh if you want to look
less like an idiot when an idiot turns
on you that helps
and the White House must love this news
BLM took millions and millions of
dollars from people and offered nothing
in return right they're BL they're bldm
black lives don't matter because they
would have done something but the good
news is I think most of the money came
from gullible white liberals not blacks
I think uh hard-working blacks would
never give their money to to an
organization this loose and this weird I
think it was never really about helping
black people it was about and this is
brilliant I wish I thought of this it
was about monetizing white liberal
virtue signaling it's a smart business
model and they just took that money I'm
now beginning to admire this person for
being so in your face about swindling
all these guilty white liberals you
can't go out and buy a fur coat after
the ship they did that's the thing yeah
exactly that's exactly Dana what Patrice
colors did she went out and bought a six
million dollar mansion she gave you know
what several hundred thousand dollar
jobs to I think one was her brother and
then it was her I think her baby's
father and you know why but but let me
ask you this
why if the inner city blacks and brown
people 80 percent want more police why
aren't they uniting and saying bring
this money back these people are frauds
it's an excellent question and I you
know we do these stories every Monday
morning you can do a story about how
terrible the weekend was in Chicago and
all the people that were either injured
in shootings or or killed many of them
are African-American Or Hispanic and
they I think that they look I'm not in
their shoes obviously obviously
um but I do wonder if they just feel
beaten down overwhelmed and they're just
trying to survive day to day and it's up
to the leadership to do something more
so you have mayor Lightfoot who is
running for reelection and is not
promising any change there's there's and
then you had even in Philly there was a
recall of the prosecutor got reelected
same thing in California so
there I don't know where that change is
going to come from now Democrats have
painted themselves into a bit of a
corner especially when it comes to
Congress on police reform last year
Republicans went pretty far down the
table to try to do a negotiation run by
Senator Tim Scott Cory Booker of New
Jersey was on the Democratic side
apparently those two have a very good
relationship but the left just wanted so
much more and so they're preventing any
progress from happening and Jim Clyburn
I think is trying to be the Elder
Statesman that says we can be smarter
about this both from a substantive
standpoint and from a political
standpoint but the left won't let it
happen they are going to con they're
going to keep doing this to them so then
then all the Republicans can say the
Democrats want to defund the police
and in the end Jessica I mean what
you've got are you know the you've got
the same scenario with and what Jesse
pointed out to was the qualified
immunity you can't take that away from a
police officer you just can't
these conversations which I think is
part of the problem only happen in
Earnest after some extreme tragedy right
a George Floyd or Tyree Nichols or
laquan McDonald and
I hope that Tim Scott and Cory Booker
who do have this great relationship can
continue with this and that they can
work the margins to the point that the
defund the police side of things and the
people on the right who are not
interested in any compromises are
rendered irrelevant and the numbers can
work out that way I mean the margins are
so slim and George Santos you know
where's who knows where he'll be next
week
um so I think that that's possible
what black lives matter the organization
did is such a betrayal of the movement
it's pretty horrifying so black lives
matter is a philosophy right it it's not
a group it's not necessarily something
that you should be giving five dollars
to ten dollars to it's an idea that
black lives should matter equally to
White lives and to Blue lives
and the corruption of that message has
set the movement back so far that people
who just want to say there's nothing
wrong with the police can point to this
and say you've con artists running the
most important Organization for this and
you're right it was mostly white people
and I would say really well-intentioned
white people who saw what happened to
George
well-intentioned white people I'm
sitting right here
they saw what happened to George Floyd
and said what can I do and they saw an
organization with the name of the thing
that they believe and it's really just
it's so fundamentally messed up because
there are great organizations that do
good work for protecting minority lives
for any cause that you can find out
there you need to do more research and
they took advantage of the fact that
people would be so upset that there
would be this frenzied giving and I
really hate that and they also Amplified
the defund the police as if it was the
policy position of the party and it
wasn't and they never said uh can we
have our money back you're not doing
with it what you said and those white
people are what would you call them I
don't know but I love the idea of
well-intentioned white people ruining
everything yeah it could be a book I
winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now